I think all of us felt that we actually
did something to help the company this
summer you always hear about internships
that you go in and you're gonna be
serving coffee this wasn't a coffee
internship at all you have to see movies
and you get to be a part of the creative
process and getting it out there in an
IMAX they actually want you to develop
your skills and they want you to
actively contribute in ways that
actually use your education and your
talents to the highest potential the
interns have a voice everybody kind of
have them as a voice yet I'm doing
things that are related to my interests
in the industry this is my second summer
interning at IMAX
everyone's very friendly and welcoming
and they treat you like you are one of
that being able to immerse myself into
all different levels of HR and a really
wonderful experiment we're doing things
from you know splicing film to checking
subtitles for a movie that hasn't even
been released yet and it's always
something different it's always
something exciting going into a theater
and checking a movie and you control the
console and you're you basically have a
private theater to yourself I mean it's
work but it's also it's a very cool
experience I've got to deal with
customers in Barcelona in Hong Kong all
over the world and that's not just
internal in our offices that's all over
the world with actual customers I work
at actual events now do I actually get
to do really cool things and they're
definitely not your typical intern
activities